[Music]
you
an undescended testicle is a condition
where one or both male reproductive
glands have not moved down from a baby's
belly or abdomen into the scrotum
normally before birth a male babies
testicles grow inside his abdomen the
testicles along with their blood vessels
travel down through tube-like structures
called inguinal canal into the scrotum
sometimes for unknown reasons one or
both testicles fail to move down into
the scrotum before birth an undescended
testicle can remain in the abdomen
or in the inguinal canals
or just above the scrotum
or they may migrate to the base of the
penis
or other areas
half of the time the testicles descend
to the scrotum within 90 days after
birth
but if they don't descend this person
may have problems having children when
he is an adult he will also have a much
higher chance of developing testicular
cancer
usually undescended testicles can be
diagnosed by physical exam
chuckles cannot be felt beneath the skin
diagnosis will be performed by
ultrasound CT scan or occasionally
laparoscopy
undescended testicles often require an
operation called an or Keo Peck see the
procedure is recommended within the
first year after birth if the baby's
testicle is in or below the inguinal
canal an open surgery may be performed
to begin the surgeon will make a small
incision in the groin the testicle will
be freed from some of the surrounding
tissues
we'll make a second incision in the
scrotum
the testicle along with its blood
vessels will be pulled down into the
scrotum where stitches will hold it in
place
finally the incisions will be closed
the stitches may be covered with skin
closure tape gauze or bandages
if the testicle is in
abdomen a laparoscopic or kiap XE may be
performed to begin the surgeon will make
two or three tiny incisions in the
baby's abdomen small tubes for a camera
and surgical instruments will be
inserted through these incisions
the surgeon will use the instruments to
free the testicle from some of the
surrounding tissue
then another incision will be made in
the bottom of the scrotum
the surgeon will insert an instrument
into this incision to reach up and pull
the testicle down into the scrotum
stitches will hold the testicle in place
within the scrotum
finally the incisions will be closed the
stitches may be covered with skin
closure tape gauze or bandages
sometimes the blood vessels going to an
undescended testicle aren't long enough
to allow the testicle to be pulled down
into the scrotum in this case the baby
may need two surgical procedures during
the first procedure some of the shorter
blood vessels will be tied off as time
passes other blood vessels will take
over supplying blood to the testicle
then in the second procedure the surgeon
will divide the shorter blood vessels
which aren't needed anymore
and the testicle will be moved down into
the scrotum stitches will hold the
testicle in place within the scrotum